[موسيقى]
احدث استخدامها فروقا جوهريه في ساحه
المعارك على مستويات
العسكريه انها الطائرات
قواعد المعركه في اكثر من مكه ولانها
اثبتت فعاليتها ورسخت نفسها مكانه مركزيه
في العمليات العسكريه المعاصره اظهرت
العديد من الدول حرصها على امتلاك هذا
النوع من الطائرات بمختلف احجامها
وانواعها واستخداماتها فكيف اصبحت
المسيرات عنصر اساسيا
صعبا في معادله الحروب الحديثه وهل يشهدوا
العالم سباقا جديدا لتطوير تقنيات هذا
السلاح والانظمه المضادله اهلا بكم في هذه
الحلقه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
بينما تشتهر الحرب في اوكرانيا يسعى طرفان
نساء لتحقيق المزيد من المكاسب في ساحه
المعركه ومع الاستخدام المكثف والمتزايد
للطائرات المسيره في هذه الحرب وفي غيرها
من النزاعات الاقليميه والدوليه خلال
السنوات الاخيره
من الحروب الحديثه
على الاهميه المتزايده للطائرات المسيره
في الحروب الحاليه والمستقبليه والمكاسب
الجو السياسيه التي تحققها للاطراف
للاطراف المتنافسه يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في
هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو فايز الدويري
الكبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من الكويت
الدكتور صالح المطيري رئيس مركز المدار
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه ومن
واشنطن الادمره القائد السابق للقياده
الوسطى الامريكيه فاهلا بهم جميعا
السنوات الخمسه الماضيه شهدت نزاعات لعبت
فيها المسيرات ادوارا هامه وحاسمه اخرها
الحرب المتوسطه حاليا في اوكرانيا ففيها
ذاع صيته الطائرات بلا طيار اكثر من اي
صراع عسكريه اخر نتعرف في هذا التقرير على
اهم الدول المنتجه والمصنعه لهذه الطائره
تاتي الولايات المتحده في مقدمه الدول
الرائده في مجال تصنيع الطائرات المسيره
اهمها
من اهم المساجرات في الاسطول الجوي
الامريكي تم استخدامهما بشكل واسع في
افغانستان والعراق لتعقب قاده الجماعات
المسلحه اسرائيل ايضا من اكبر المنتج
ومصدريه الطائرات المسيره ومن اهمها
المسيره ايتان التي تعرف ايضا باسم هيرن
تي بي وهي اكبر مسيره تابعه لسلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى طائرته هيرميس
900 التي استخدمت في الحرب على غزه عام
2014 وفي شن هجمات واغتيالات وعمليه
الصين ايضا زادت من انتاج طائراتها
الروسيه التي تعتبر ارخص بكثير من نظراتها
الغربيه ومن اهمها
ww.g 700 التي تت وبسرعتها العاليه
وحمولتها الكبيره والقدره على تنفيذ مهام
الهجوم والاستطلاع اما تركيا فقد برزت في
مجال تصنيع المسيرات في السنوات الاخيره
واصبحت واحده من ست دول في العالم في هذا
المجال
ولاعبه المسيارات التركيه مثل برقدار
مختلفه انواعها وتي اي اي انك دورا مهما
في انتصار اذربيجان على ارمينيا في الحرب
الاخيره
كبستخدمت بشكل واسع من قبل القوات
الاخرانيه في استهداف القواعد الروسيه في
المقابل استخدمت روسيا مسيرات ايرانيه من
بينها شاهد 100 وسته 136 ومهاجر سته
وتتميز هذه المسيرات بخفه وزنها وانخفاض
سعرها وتتهم ايران بتزويد الجماعات
المسلحه تابعه لها في المنطقه العربيه
بهذه الطائرات
الطائرات المسيره العسكريه تقسم الى 300
حسب تصنيف الخبراء في هذا المجال الاولى
التي يبلغ وزنها اقل من 150 كغم وتضم
طائرات صغيره تستعمل عاده للاستطلاع مثل
سكاي لارج
الثانيه وزنها ما بين 150 كغم الى 600
كيلوغرام وتضم سيارات تكتيكيه مثل واتش
كيبر التي استعملت لاول مره في افغانستان
عام 2003 للمراقبه وجمع المعلومات الفئه
الثالثه يبلغ وزنها اكثر من 600 كيلوغرام
وتتضمن مسيرات هجوميه واستراتيجيه مثل
قلوب الهوك وريفر الامريكيهتين اللتين
استخدمها في افغانستان العراق ومن المحتمل
ان تتغير هذه التصنيفات مع تطور
التكنولوجيا وظهوره معدات جديده ذات خصائص
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
هذه القطع العسكريه الصغيره بدلت في
الحروب موازين القوى وغيرت في المفاهيم
معنى التفوق العسكري
الطائرات المسيره على امتداد الجغرافيا في
مناطق النزاعات من فك التستحوذ اهتمام
اطراف الحروب دولا وجماعات المسلحه
ادوارها لا تنحصر في وظيفه واحده فمنها
الانذار المبكر والاستطلاع وجمع المعلومات
والتعقب وتدمير اهداف ثابته او متحركه
في الحرب اليمنيه وفي اقليم كربا واخيرا
في حرب اوكرانيا حيث يعزز الروس
والاكراميون ترساناتهم العسكريه بهذا
النوع من الطائرات من مصدرين مختلفين
والمصدرون هنا قصه سباق اخر في مضمار
التسلح
فاذا كان الروس يعتمدون على المسيرات
الايرانيه فانه اوكرانيا تتمتع بمخزون من
المسيارات التركيه وذك ملمح من ملامح تنفس
جيو سياسي لقوتين اقليمتين في المنطقه من
المهم لكليهما ان يكون رقما فاعلا في
صناعه السلاح عالميه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده السباقه في تصنيع المسيارات فان
حرب اوكرانيا كانت فرصه لتجريب النسخه
المطوره من طائره شبح العنقاء فقد كان
يجري تطويرها قبل الحرب وفي ابريل الماضي
اعلنت واشنطن تزويده
منها مع اجراء تعديلات تراع احتياجات
القوات الاوكرانيه
ما يجري في اوكرانيا يحفز بلا ريب تفكير
صناع السياسات العسكريه وشركات التصنيع
الكبرى فميزه مسيرات افلاتها من انظمه
الدفاع الجوي التقليديه التي لم تستطع في
كثير من الاحيان رصدها وتدميرها من المهم
بالنسبه للمصنعين اذا تطوير مضادات جويه
لهذه المسيارات لا سيما ان امتلاكها ليس
حكرا على القوه الكبرى الضليعه في قطاع
التصنيع العسكري
القدرات الايرانيه في هذا القطاع مثلا
تقلق الدول الغربيه وتثير مخاوفها من
تزويد طهران لحلفائها في الشرق الاوسط
بالطائرات المسير وذاك ما يحدث تهديدا
امنيا جديدا لحلفاء الغرب في المنطقه
وباعتبارها عنصرا جديدا في منظومه التسلح
الدوليه تطرح الطائرات المسيره تحديا اخر
على المستوى الاخلاقيه فبالنظر الى احداث
كثيره سابقه اوقعت فيها ضحايا مدنيين
وابرياء تبرز الحاجه الى اجراء تعديلات
على قوانين الحروب والى اقرار معايير
ومبادئ لاستخدام المسيارات ضمن القانون
الدولي الانساني
اهلا وسهلا بك هذه الطائرات المسيره كيف
انتقلت من مجرد مهام استطلاعيه واحيانا
ضربات محدوده ضد مجموعات معينه الى كل هذا
الصيت الان في الحروب
بمراحل رئيسيه اولا على الانطلاق الاولى
في الحرب العالميه الاولى واول من صنعها
بريطانيا وامريكا الحرب العالميه الاولى
نقطه التحول الثاني في عام
1935 تم احداث تطوير جذري عليها بحيث
اصبحت تستخدم لاغراض تدريب وحدات الدفاع
الجوي كاهداف ثابته معلقه في السماء او
بطيئه الحركات في السماء ثم بعد ذلك جاءت
حرب فيتنا فاخذت مجال ابعد اخذت بدات
تستخدم في التصوير عمليات الاستطلاع توجيه
ايران المدفعيه الى غير ذلك وهذا كل
المراحل امريكيه فقط هذه المعظمها امريكي
الان في حرب دخلت اسرائيل على الخلق
واستخدمت استخدام محدود جدا وقد يكون
الكلام مفاجئ في حرب عام 1973 على الواجهه
السوريه واستخدمت في اطار التشويش
والمراقبه والاستطلاع ثم جاءت همم الاعلام
الفارقه
في احداث سبتمبر بعد احداث سبتمبر بدا
توظيف العمليات ولكن هذا التوظيف كان من
قبل دول ضد تنظيمات صنفت على انهاء
ارهابيه او ما شابه ذلك وبرزت بصوره واضحه
في افغانستان وقتلت حسب التاثيرات ما بين
750 الى 1000 افغاني منهم 20 قائد ثم جاءت
عمليات الاغتيال المعروفه العولقي الظواهر
همم قائد القدس اذن نحن نقول بدا التوسع
في وظيفه الاستخدام عمليات من قبل دول
جهات ضد تنظيمات او اشخاص وقدمت الشيء
الكثير الان في خمس سنوات كما اشار
التقرير واشاره الى خمسه حروف رئيسيه
لماذا هذا التحول لانه ان كانت تختلفت
فبدات الان الامكانات واسعه بدات هذه
الطائره لا اقول تغني عن لكنها قد تقوم
بادوار جزئيه مما كان يوكل الى الطائرات
المقاتله لماذا لانها على سبيل المثال هذه
الطائره تختصر القوه البشريه الى اكثر من
50%
تصفر الخسائر البشريه بالنسبه للتيارين
تقدم استدامه بعض الطائرات تطير لمده 60
ساعه في الجو وهي تبعث لك على سبيل المثال
هذه سياتي عليها في هذا اليوم في هذا
اليوم عرض الطائره في معرض الطائرات في في
في الصين تطير لمس عابرا للقارات تطير
لمسافه 10,000 كيلو متر تحمل 16 صاروخ او
قذيفه نحن نتحدث عن ثوره نتحدث عن ثوره
لكن ده يعني اقول لماذا هذا التغير لانه
الوظائف والمهام التي اكلت لها اصبحت اوسع
بدات تدخل من قبل بدي اطلع النهارده
امي عملها اذا انهت بعد انتهاء العمليات
العسكريه وبدات تقدم خدمات لا تقدمها
الطائرات المجنحه اللي طائرات ثابته
الجناح على ابي سن سبيل المثالي تبعث
طائره استطلاع تبقى في الجو لمده اربعه
الى خمس ساعات تبعث لك في افغانستان كانت
تبعث
شرائط فيديو
بواقع 500 ساعه يومي 500 ساعه من الاشرطه
فبعثت الطائرات تفرق وتكون تحوي على
معلومات صارت تقدم للقائد العسكري خاصه
الذي يخوض المعركه الهجوميه تقدم له صوره
حيه عن ارض المعركه يستطيع ان يبدل في
اتجاهات القوات اولاويات العمليات الى غير
ذلك حتى وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه الان واخذت
ادوارها الرئيسيه والنقطه الاخيره في
عوجها حتى لا اطيل اقول النقطه الفارقه في
استخدامه في استخدامها عندما تم دمجها في
العمليات المشتركه ما هي العمليات المش
عندما تشترك القوات البريه والبحريه
والجويه في معركه واحده الان دخل عنصر
الرابع اضافه الى عنصر الفضاء وهو عنصر
الطائرات المشيئه مثل ما صارت همم
لودوري الولايات المتحده كانت هي السباق
في هذا الموضوع نسال الادميرال ويليامفلون
اهلا وسهلا بك عندما بدات الولايات
المتحده هذا النوع من الطائرات هل كانت
تتوقع لها مثل هذا الانتشار العالمي
من حقائق تاريخيه حول الطائرات
بعد السياق حسب خبر
المتحده الامريكيه بدات تطبيق في حرب
فيتنام
بهذا الامر كانت لدينا طبعا بعد
عمليه في ذلك الوقت
اكتشفناه في ذلك الوقت هو اهميتها في
عمليات الاستطلاع وبامكانه تلك الطائرات
تطيره في
اماكنها بالنسبه للقوات التالي كان هذا
يقدم حمايه للقوات لكن التكنولوجيا في ذلك
الوقت
لما تكون متطوره بشكل التي عليها اليوم
اذا
التكنولوجيا تطورت بشكل كبير وفي ذلك
الوقت نذكر ان بعض الطائرات كانت تختفي
لكن التكنولوجيا تطورت وحسن مستوى هذه
الطائرات وقبل 20 سنه
عندما بلغ فجر التكنولوجيا حديثه جديده
عن الجانب الالكتروني الذي بات يستخدم في
المجال العسكري وكان بالامكان استخدام
قطاع غيار صغيره والدقيقه الشيء الاخر
ايضا
امكانيه جمع المعلومات والقيام بطلعات
الاستطلاعيه لهذه الطائرات
وتزويد القائد العسكري بالمعلومات على
مدار الساعه فيها السابق معظم
البيانات والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه كانت
في شكل صور
ولكن الان هناك تطور كبير وامكانيه
لارسالته مقاطع فيديو
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدات
بتطوير
طائرات مسيره لي بامكانها ان تبقى في
الجوله فتره طويله وايضا تحلق على
علوش بنفس الوقت
ترسل الصور ومقاطع فيديو للميتان هذا كله
بشكل
ليتم استخدامها هذه الطائرات في مهمات
هجوميه قتاليه
بامكان هذه الطائرات ان تحمل همم الصواريخ
وبامكانها ان تبقى فتره اطول في الجو
وبامكانها ايضا التوغل في مناطق خطره
وتتفضل اضيفكم طبعا بالاشاره الى بعض من
هذه المهامات في افغانستان
وايضا اخرى في العالم لم يكن بالامكان
الوصولها في السابق او اماكن
ولا تريد طبعا
غامر فيها بالتالي بدا امريكا
شان بالنسبه لي اي التكنولوجيا حديثه
فهنا هناك فتره من الزمن يبدا فيها التطور
بشكل سري في البدايه تكون امكانيات هذه
الطائرات
متواضعه وتكون محدوده ولكن بعد ذلك نشهد
تطور كبير منذ 20 سنه
راينا تطورا كبيرا لهذه الطائرات حيث
اكتسبته قدره عاليه
وبالامكان استخدامها في مهمات متنوعه
ومختلفه
يسعدكم
قيل بان هذه الطائرات حاسمه في اوكرانيا
اقول لا ليست
الامر كذلك لم نشهد بانها فعلا حاسمه ايضا
شيء اخر التكنولوجيا
تتطور يوم بعد اخر وهي تتكيف حسب الحاجات
حسب المهمات وهناك الكثير من الاموال
ينبغي تحسينها هناك شيء اخر ايضا
الطائرات
تحل محل
القوات التقليديه لا اعتقد ان هذا سيحدث
في القريبه العاجل والسبب خلف ذلك هو ان
هناك
ضروره لتواجد العنصر البشري الذي يراقب
الوضع الذي يجمع المعلومات التي يتخذ
القرار
لا اتوقع ان هذه الطائرات تترك لحالها
تجوا وتطير في الاجواء من دون تحكم العنصر
البشري اذا العنصر البشري دائما العبد
دوران السياسيه من اجله برمجه هذه
الطائرات
وتوجيها في المناطق التي همم
مثلا
الان نتحدث عن الذكاء الاصطناعي هو الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليس همم
اوتوماتيكيا هناك دائما حاجه لتواجد
العنصر البشري
لبرمجه هذه الاجهزه
البشري الاتحاد القرارات
انا هاسيبها من اجل تشغيل لكل هذه الانظمه
اذا اذا بعد هذه المعلومات العسكريه
التقنيه بين اللواء فايز الدويري
والادميرال فعلا نتوجه اكثر الى جانب
يتعلق همم دكتور المطيري
بالطائرات المسيره الان كا اا اداه لتوسيع
النفوذ
للدول الدوري السياسي للدول وهنا برزت في
الفتره الاخيره خاصه الحديث عن المسيرات
التركيه والمسيرات الايرانيه كيف كيف
برايك همم سمحت همم هذه الطائرات لهذه
الدول بان تكون لها هذه المكانه وهذا
الدور
شكرا استاذ محمد لن اضيف كثيرا على ضيفك
الكريمين من الناحيه العسكريه لكن انا
اعتقد بانه ايضا من الجانب الاخلاقي والذي
ذكرتموه حول استخدام مثل هذه الاسلحه او
المسيارات يعني العسكريون دائما يقولوا من
يملك السماء يفوز بالحظ رغم انه لديهم
ايضا قاعده لانه لا يمكن حسب معركه
بالقوات الجويه فقط دون القوات
الاخرى من القوات او الاخرى من القوات
العسكريه انا الجانب الاخلاقي يعني ان هذه
المسيرات قد جاءت للدول التي تستخدمها
بضربات التي لا اب لها التي لا يراد ان ان
تتبناها احد كما حصل مثلا في سوريا انت
تعرف بان المسيرات الاسرائيليه ثقيل وتجوب
الاجواء الروسيه وتنفذ الكثير من
العامليات التي لا ترغب اسرائيل على سبيل
المثال انت الاجواء السوريه
سوريا سوريا
كذلك تم استخدامها في ليبيا عندما
مره اخرى في الاجواء الليبيه استخدمت
تركيا عندما دعمت حكومه السراج ان ذلك لم
تقدمت قوات ما يطلق عليه الجيش الوطني
اوحبته دون ان تعلن ذلك او دون ان تتبنى
ذلك بشكل صريح كما استخدمت ايضا القوات
التركيه هذا السلاح في سوريا عند ما ردت
على مقتل اكثر من عسكري تركي في ادلب انا
ذاك وقامت باهداف ناجحه ونوعيه همم
استخدمتها كذلك ايران انا اعتقد انه ما
يحصل او ضربات التي وجهت الى الامارات او
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تعرف بان اكثر
من 850 طائره مسيره هاجمت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في مواقع نفطيه ومواقع مدنيه
واخرى قيل بانها من الحوثي بينما التقنيه
والان ربما يؤكد هذا الواقع الحالي بانه
التقدم الذي حصل في الجانب الايراني
مثل هذا السلاح ربما زودت همم اي فرق او
اي منشات اخرى هذه الدوله او تلك وبالتالي
هنا تظهر خطوره هذا السلاح اولا هو سلاح
رخيص نوعا ما لا يتقيد بقيود سياسيه
وعسكري كما يحصل مثلا عندما تريد الدوله
شراء سلاح معين من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما تعلم طائرات الاف 35 وما
حصل من هذه القيود او الاشتراطات الصعبه
ناهيك ان كثير من الدول الان لديها هذه
التقنيه في صناعه مثل هذه الاسلحه او
الانواع البسيطه منها انا اعتقد انه ايران
على سبيل المثال التي استثمرت او اذا جازي
للتعبير التي انفقت المليارات لتطوير
برنامج الصاروخ البالستي
ومحاوله منها للوصول الى ابعد من حدودها
او ليكون لها تاثيره ابعد من ذلك دعما
طبعا لتوجهاتها للاذرع الاخرى في المنطقه
فالان وجدت ضارتها في مثل هذه النوعيه من
التسريحات تقنيه بسيطه بالامكان استخدامها
لا تحتاج الى مطارات لا تحتاج الى قطع
غيار بعضها اصلا لهد واحد كم على طريقه
اليابان كما يقال وبالتالي هذا هو التوسع
اللي ذكرته الاستراتيجي الان استخدام مثل
هذه المسيرات بهذا التوسع انا اعتقد بانه
استشراف المستقبل العسكريين يجب ان يكون
محل اعتباط وتقدير خصوصا بان التجربه
الوحيده الواسعه في الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه وانا اعتقد بانه استطاعت الدولتين
استخدام سواء روسيا اوكرانيا استخدام هذه
التقنيه استطاعت ايضا ان تطور المضادات
الارضيه للتقليل منها لكنها تبقى تحت
التقييم لمزيد من طبعا المراجعات لوضعها
في الخطط الاستراتي لكن خطورتها ما ذكر
لانها سهله الوصول من همم القوات
استخدمتها مثلا همم استخدمها حزب الله ضد
همم
طبعا الصهيوني في اسرائيل استخدمت كذلك في
همم جورنو كهرباء بنجاح شديد استخدمت ايضا
في دول يعني بعيده في نزاعات كثيره حتى في
يعني الان دول افريقيا لديها عدد كبير من
هذه الطائرات المسيره فبالتالي لن تكون
حكرا لانها لس ليست عليها قيود كثيره
بامكان تصنيعه بسهوله استخدامه سهوله
حملها وبالتالي ستوسع كثيرا من نفوذ هذه
الدول المملكه العربيه السعوديه اخيرا
يبدو انها ايضا اظهرت نوعا ما في في
المعرض الطيران الاخير ويبدو انها بصدد
انتاج نوعين او كما اطلق عليهم السموم
والعصر واستطاعت ان يعني تتبنى هذا التوجه
او هذا التغيير الاستراتيجي العسكري لان
كما تعرف دول الخليج فقط المليارات يمكن
اكثر دول في المنطقه تنفق في التسليح
التقليدي هي دول الخليج العربي والتي يعني
اثبتت بعد سنوات بانها لم تكن كافيه
لحمايه حدودها
وتاكيد الكلام هذا حتى الجزائر في الفتره
الاخيره اعلنت عن همم بدايه الشروع في
تاسيس نواه بحثيه وعسكريه لهذا النوع من
الطائرات بالنسبه لايران وتركيا هذا
استدعت للفخر الرئيس الايراني قال نحن
تحولنا من بلد يستورد الاسلاك الشائكه الى
بلد قادر على تصدير هذا النوع من الطائرات
الرئيس اردوغان قال انا لا اذهب الى اي
مكان الا واسال عن هذه الطائرات المسيره
الان همم قيل بان الطائرات التركيه هي
افضل
كما ثبت على الاقل في في اوكرانيا لكن
الطائرات الايرانيه ارخص الان لو اردنا ان
نبحث كفاءه هذه الطائرات كما جرب على
الاقل
بارق دار وطائره شاهد طائره شاهده طاهره
انتحاري كماشي تكلفه 20,000$ تذهب في رحله
واحده تذهب وفجاه هناك
نعملها خمسه مليون
تكلف خمسه ملايين ليست رخيصه
هناك طائرات في امريكا تضاهي تضاهي تكلفه
طائرات الاف 15 واف 16 وهذا قد اذا اجتاح
المجال قد يتحدث عنه فبالتالي اذا
المقارنه بين كل النوعين انا يعني لا
استطيع ان نقارن بين سلاحين تستخدم لوظائف
مختلفه
عندما نتحدث عن طائره نحن تحدثنا يعني او
الحديث عنها يكون كالاتي انها استطاعت ان
تقدم شياه حاسمت الحرب
حسناتها على مراحل وبالتالي استطاع دمرت
اكثر من 240 دبابه اكثر من 134 عربه قتال
الى الى غير ذلك في سوريا في حادثه ادلب
اشار لها الدكتور المطيري كان الرد ساحق
والارقام قد لا يؤخذ بها يعني الحديث عن
2200 جندي يسيروا في هذه الغارات اذا ان
اقارن بينها الطائرات التركيه والطائرات
همم الايرانيه لا يوجد مقارنه لان اسس
التصميم مختلفه والمهم المنوطه بانها
مختلفه لكن هذا اخ محمد قد يطرح همم نوع
من التشاؤل في في التقرير تم الحديث وانت
تتحدث ان هناك تصنيف همم حسب الوزن اخشى
ما اخشى ان هذا التصنيف لن يتم اعتماد
المستقبل انه سافرح تصور اذا سمحت لي تفضل
اولا انا اتوقع انه هناك سيكون الحديث عن
ما يطلق عليهم
طائرات صغيره وبدا الحديث يتسرب عن الدبور
الاسود
جرام تكلفه 175000 دولار تقدم 16 جرام
وبالتالي تستخدم في عمليات التجسس
والمراقبه
هذا سيكون المايك جديد
بدايته الدبور الاسود
ناتي للتصنيف الاخر ما هو معروف حاليا
بحزمه الطائرات الحاليه وننتقل الى الجيل
القادم وهو الطائرات عابره القارات واشرت
لها هذا اليوم في الطائره الصينيه
هذا غير مسبوق بالنسبه نوع من الطائرات
التي عينته الان في الصين
هذه الطائرات تطير الى 10,000 تحمل 16
قذيفه او صاروخ
تدوم اكثر من 60 ساعه في الجو اذا هي تقدم
لك امتيازات هي لن تغني عن اتفقنا لا يمكن
ان تكون بديلا للطائرات ولكنها تقدم اضافه
النوويه وهنا عندما اقول الجيل الثالث
ونتحدث عن هذا المستوى بمحركات هوربينيه
او محركات نفاثه
اذا ربطت مع الذكاء الاصطناعي نحن نكون
امام افاق لا نستطيع ادراك ما هييتها في
اللحظه الحاليه لانه سرعه تطور
التكنولوجيا لكنها ستبقى عاملا مساعدا في
كسب الحرب لن تكون العامل الحاسم لن تكون
العامل الرئيسي لن تكون بديلا للقوات
الارضيه ولا للقوات الجويه
ولكنها تساعد الاصناف الاخرى في تحقيق
وانجاز مهامها لماذا من اجل تصفير همم
التكلفه البشريه في الطيارين تخفيض الجهد
تخفيض المال تخفيض الوقت وبالتالي نحن
امام افاق ولكن كل ما اتسعد دائره
الاستخدام ضمن مفهوم العمليات المشتركه
كلما
تعاظم هذا الدور لهذه الطائرات اثرت ايضا
اشار همم
الى ان هذه النوع من الطائرات لن لن يعوض
باي حاجه من الاحوال المقاتلات الحربيه
هنا نسال السيد الادميرال ويلي اام لن
تعوض الطائرات المقاتله الحربيه ولكن على
الاقل هل خففت من اعبائها بمعنى لم تعد
المقاتلات
مدعوه للقيام بمكانه تقوم به في السابق
بكل تفاصيله
بالنسبه
للمهمات التي تقوم بها هذه الطائرات هي
تختلف بالنسبه للطائرات
التي هي تقوم بها الطائرات
المهوله ولكن في المستقبل طبعا قد نشهد
تطور في هذه المهمات هناك
ستكون طبعا في المستقبل القريب استخدام
الطائرات الماهوله والطائرات الغير مجهوله
بنفسها المطاف حسب المهمات وحسب الاستقدام
نراه في اوكرانيا اليوم في تقديره وتطور
سري لتكنولوجيا في مجال الطائرات ال سيرا
من اجل القيام بمهمات مختلفه بعد هذه
المهمات هي
ترتبطت بجمع المعلومات
والاستطلاع المهمات اخرى هي مهمه هجوميه
مهمات قتاليه
وايضا
سنرى تطور التكنولوجيا
مثلا قبل 15 سنه
العمل الذي قام به بعض المهندسين
والطلعه على طائره مسيره بهذا الحجم
فوق فوق
[موسيقى]
للغايه هو هذه هي الطائرات انا بامكانها
بطريقه
[موسيقى]
ان تدخل من خلال فتحه النافذه وتقوم بجمع
المعلومات داخل تخرج وتعود مره اخرى اذا
كان هذا قبل 10 سنوات
همم في البحر ايضا على مستوى سطح البحر
وايضا تحت البحر بالتالي التكنولوجيا
تستخدم في اتجاهات مختلفه للقيام بمهامه
مختلفه طبعا
همم استخدامات متعدده لكن اوكرانيا الان
تعلمنا الكثير من خفايا هذه التكنولوجيا
التحدي الكبير الان ربما دكتور صالح
المطيري ان القضيه لم تعد فقط قضيه حروب
بين دول ونزاعات كبرى همم هناك تحدي امني
يتعلق بامكانيه وصول هذا النوع من
الطائرات بمختلف انواعها ان لم تكون
الكبيره والباهظه فعل الاقل الصغيره
لمجموعات مسلحه في مناطق مختلفه ونحن نعلم
بان عدد من الدول العربيه
والاقليميه لها نزاعات مختلفه هل هل هناك
خوف امني وعسكري غير مصبوغ في هذه المساله
صحيح يعني
واقعا وليس خوفا فقط لانه تعرف المنطقه
تعرض دوله الامارات هل يعني هل تعرف حجم
المخاطر التي تعرض لها مثلا مطار
دبي في الامارات عندما حامض فقط او عندما
تم رصد احدى هذه المسيرات عندما ضربت
الناقلات في ممر الخليج العربي في مضيق
هرمز انت استاذ محمد كم كان تاثير هذه
الضربات يعني موجعا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
ولا الامنيه في ان واحد واثار قلق يعني
اقتصادي
رهيب على دول منطقه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ايضا حدث ولا حرج في ضربات التي
حصلت انا فقط احب ارجعك ليس بعيدا استاذ
محمد اذا كنت تذكر حادثه الطائره التي طار
بها مراهق ونزل في نساء هت- الكريم لان
ذلك بالطائر الشراعيه كيف اهتز العالم انا
ذاك بالرغم من انه هذه طائره يعني شراعيه
بسيطه وليست مسلحه الان قس على ذلك مد
كثير مثل هذا النوع من المسيرات ومثل هذه
التقنيه التي تصل الى ابسط حتى يعني جماعه
ارهابيه او جماعه معارضه او جماعه مسلحه
في في شتى انواع دول العالم او مدعومه من
دوله لديها هذه التقنيه انت تعرف الان
مثلا القيود التي توجد على الاسلحه
التقليديه مثلا ولا تستطيع كثير من من
الجماعات خصوصا ما اقصد فيه سواء الجماعات
الانفصاليه او الجماعات الثائره او
الجماعات المختلفه التي لها يعني همم توجه
معين عقائدي او او قومي هذه التقنيه اذا
ما وصلت وهي بالفعل لدى البعض منها الان
ستغير بكثير من همم مفاهيم اللعبه في
الاداره السياسيه وحتى في الدعم انا يعني
فقط اود ان يشير الى ان مثل هذا السلاح
وان كان هناك استشراف لكي يكون له دور
كبير في المعارك التقليديه ال- مستقبلا
واكيد يعني سواء المصنعون او العسكريون
الاستراتيجيون س- سيريدوا تطويرا لمهام
هذه النوعيه من المسيرات اكثر من الرصد
والاستهداف وتحديد الاحداثيات ستكون بديلا
للاقمار الصناعيه وتعرف استاذ محمد واعرف
ضيوفك الكرام كان هي مكلفه استخدام
الاقمار الصناعيه او ان تقوم دوله ما
بعينها باطلاق قمر صناعيا كم يكلفها من
الاستثمار او من القيود القانونيه
والدوليه لاطلاق مثل هذا القمر الصناعي
الان انا يعني هناك تقارير كثيره تشير الى
ان مثل هذه الطائرات ستقوم او ستكون بديلا
مقبولا ومفيدا ايضا بدل من الاقمار
الصناعيه وبالتالي سيكون لها خطوره اكثر
من خطورتها كثيره يعني او همم توجيه
تدميري انما كتحديد الاحداثيات لاسلحه
اخرى او استخدامها لاغراض اخرى فهذا
الجانب بالتاكيد هو تحت النظر العسكريين
واستشارهم هناك من يرى بانه ستكون الغاما
جويه يعني ممكن تطويرها لكي تصبح على
ارقام الجويه فانا اعتقد تحديدا في دول
المنطقه في دول الخليج ان تعرف يعني
السباق التسلق تعرف قضيه المفاعل النووي
الايراني قضيه محاوله الاصول الى سلاح
نووي في المنطقه هنا سباق يعني سباق نحو
التوصل الى مثل هذه التقنيه وانا اعتقد ان
دول الخليج والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
التي اعلنت كما ذكرت في مداخله سابقا
بانها تتوجه نحو تطوير مثل هذا السلاح
وانتاج مثل هذه الطائرات المسيره لمحاوله
خلق توازن وحمايه همم يعني عسكريه
واستراتيجيه وامنيه وهي اقل بالتاكيد كل
الفتاه من التسريحه التقليدي او الطائرات
وهي لا تغني بالتاكيد عن الطائرات كما ذكر
همم الضيوف الكرام لكنها بالتاكيد ستكون
يعني لها قيمه واهميه في حمايه همم
المنطقه
همم كيفيه التصدي لان نتحدث عن هذه
الطائرات وي دائما بس لما تابعنا في
التقرير وغيره ب- رصدها والتصدي لها عمليه
معقده تحتاج الى انظمه دفاع مختلفه ليست
للانظمه الدفاع الكلاسيكيه الان كيف يمكن
التصدي لهذا النوع لان الان خوف مش فقط من
بعد الطائرات وانما ايضا من اسراب من
طائرات ال- ال- المسيره تاتي مجموعه كامله
وهذه صعب التصدي لها مثلما وقع في قاعده
تحميمين السوريه في 2018 وتسببت في اضرار
كبيره همم الان هناك حديث عن امكانيه
التصدي للطائرات المسيره بطائرات مسيره
اعتراضيه لو تحدثنا اكثر عن كيفيه التصدي
يا سيدي يعني الدكتور صالح عشار استخدم
مصطلح على الغرام الجويه وهي صياغه اخرى
لما تفضل به لانه احد الاستخدامات
المستقبليه ان تستخدم كعدون ناريه او حقول
الغرام جويه اي بمعنى اخر ان تطلق والمئات
في الحروب اللي بين الدول ذات النزاع
المنخفض الكلفه لكن اذا تحدثنا عن صراع
بين دول كبيره على سبيل المثال لقدر الله
امريكا والصين نتوقع استخدام الالاف من
هذه الطائرات
بصوره متزامنه هنا تكمن مشكله الدفاع
الجوي لماذا لانه اصلا هذا يغير في
المفاهيم الاستراتيجي هناك مفهوم يطلق
عليها اسياد الجويه وعنينا من الدول
العربيه في حروبنا مع اسرائيل عندما دمرت
المطارات والطائرات والسباحه الاجواء ثم
ياتيونها ما يطلق عليه التفوق الجوي ان
يبقى لدي قدرات محدوده لاستخدام الطائرات
الان مفهوم السياده الجويه
والتفوق الجوي سينتهي وسيتم استبداله
بمصطلحات جديده بسبب النقطه التي انت
طرحتها عندما يتم تحريك العشرات والمئات
من هذه القطارات بصوره متزامله هذا ماذا
يتطلب الان اليه التعامل مع هذه طائرات لا
تجدي الوسائل الحاليه ان نفعل الكامل
الكامل لماذا من منظور الكلفه انت تتحدث
عن طائره 20,000
دولار وتتحدث عن صاروخ الباتريوت مليون
دولار انت تطلق يجب ان تطلق صاروخين على
الهدف الواحد انت تطلق اثنين مليون مقابل
20,000 دولار فهذه المعادن لا يمكن ان
تستوي اذن الان احنا همم الوضع الحالي
تستخدم الاسلحه البسيطه
الرشاشات الرباعيه والرشاشات العاديه لانه
طائرات الايرانيه هي طائرات بطيئه تطير
على عن همم ارتفاعات منخفضه لديها صوت
مزعج يمكن صوتها سرعتها بطيئه الصوت يسرق
قبل الوصولها تعطيك فرصه الاختفاء وفره
التصدي لكن انا تحدثت قبل شويه وقلت اذا
ما دخل همم الذكاء الاصطناعي هنا تبرز
المشكله وهنا تبرز الحاجه على سبيل المثال
الرادارات الان تعمل بناء على المساحه
المقطعيه للهدف معظم الرادارات الحاليه
صممت لتكشف الطائرات الطائرات المقاتله
وبالتالي ردا على هذا الرادار تم اختراع
الطائرات اداء نبات شفته التخفي رابتر في
22 الاف 35 بعد الطائرات الصينيه الان
المقطع المساحه المقطعيه لهذه الطائرات
صغيره جدا لا يكتشف الرادار في معظم
الحالات اذا عليك ان تطور التقنيه التقنيه
الدفاع الجوي بدءا من الرادار ووصول الى
الصاروخ الى وجود ايجاد
صناعات غير مكلفه
يعني يجب على ان تكون الوسيله تتناسب مع
مع الهدف والا ستبقى معادله خاسره ومختلفه
كالعاده نقوم في نهايه الحلقه بجوله بين
ضيوفنا وهذه المره اللي نرى همم افاق
ومستقبل هذا النوع من الطائرات نبدا
بالادمر ثم الدكتور مطيري بالواء فايز
الدويري
الاميره الان
مدير الدراسات في مركز الامن الامريكي
الجديد قال انتشار هذه الانظمه سيستمر
لانها في النهايه هي قوه جويه
بثمن زهيد هل تسيطر هذا الراي
نعم
مستمر والتكلفه تبعنا
وهناك امكانيه لانتاج المزيد والكثير من
هذه الطائرات لكن طبعا بنفس المطار كما
تفضل ضيفكم الكريم
هناك نوع من الطائرات
وحيده استخدام
هناك الكثير من العمل والبحث يتم القيام
به الان من اجل التصدي لهذه الطائرات يمكن
برمجه بعض هذه الطائرات للذهاب الى اماكن
طائرات
سبسك
التغيير اتجاهها وتقوم بتتبع الهدف ايضا
هناك تكنولوجيا في طور التطوير الكثير من
البحث سيتم القيام به الان وهناك عمل كبير
ستظهر نتائج
كثيره الان تظهر
تباعا في اوكرانيا وتكنولوجيا سات تستمر
في التطور وهناك كثير من الطائرات المسيره
تطلع بمهامه مختلفه لذلك اعتقد ان هذا
التطور سيستمر
والدول ستعمل بشكل كبير من اجل الخروج
بطرق الاعتراض هذه الطائرات المسيره
الدكتور مطيري
نعم انا اعتقد السيد محمد بانه لو كانت
هذه الطائرات يعني وهذا هذه افتراض رغم
انها موجوده كما ذكر اللواء فايز قبل قليل
منذ 1930 لكن لو كانت هذه الطائرات وهذه
التقنيه بهذا الشكل موجوده في حرب امريكا
في فيتنام لا ما خسرت كما تقول الارقام
الولايات المتحده اكثر من 3000 700 طائره
مقاتله و 4900 طائره هليكوبتر او طائره
رسميه وخسرت هذا العدد من الطيارين من
القتلى او الاسرى وتغير شكل الحرب
الفيتاميه تماما انا بظني لانه هذه
التقنيه الان موجوده هناك من الخبراء
العسكريين ما يقول بان وجود المسيرات او
النقل التي احدثتها المسيرات في حرب رغما
تقيمها الان يعني لن يكون نهائيا لان هذه
الحرب الوحيد الواسع حرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه التي استخدمت بهذا الشكل وانما
استخدمت باستهداف بعض المقاتلين او
استهداف بعض
او حتى بشكل همم يعني قصير جدا في نهجورنو
كاراباخ لكن انا ظني بانه هذه النوعيه كما
شبهها احد الخبراء العسكريين بانه كا وجود
السلاح الرشاش في اول ظهور لا في همم
السلاح التقليدي او في الرمايه احدث نقله
نوعيه فاعتقد بانه ما زال هناك الكثير
لاستشراق مثل هذا الاستخدام لان يبقى
اعاده النظريه او مفهوم السيطره الجويه
بان اصبحت هذه السيطره او امكانيه السيطره
على الجو او مثل السماء كما يقال سهله
ومتاحه ولا تحتاج الى انفاق هذه المليارات
في بعض البرامج سواء في الصواريخ الفارسيه
او في بعض الحروب لكن بالمقابل ايضا هناك
بالتاكيد تطور اخر للتصدي لهذا لهذا النوع
من الصراع كما حصل روسيا استوعبت في الحرب
الاوكرانيه هذا الحجم او الاستخدام
للمسيرات من قبل اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده همم صرحت اليوم بانها لن
تزود اوكرانيا بطائرات مسيره متطوره
بمعنى ان لدي المزيد ولدي ما هو افضل
بكثير ولكن لن اعطيه الان لاوكرانيا يا
سيدي يعني هذا الحديث تحدث به الرئيس بيدن
اكثر من مره وكان هناك سقف الطلبات عالي
جدا بالنسبه للرئيسكي تحدث عن الطائرات
ثابته الجناح تحدث عن
هيمارس 300 كلم تحدث عن بعض الصواريخ 165
وتحدث عن دبابات ابرامز ولكن هناك خطوط
حمراء لا يمكن للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انت تجاوزه لانه تجاوزها يعني الاحتكاك
المباشر مع روسيا هي الان نعم تواجه روسيا
ولكن بطريقه غير مباشره وضمن مقوله همم
تمكين الجيش الاوكراني من الدفاع عن نفسه
وهذه العباره مفتوحه الدفاحه حتى استعاده
الحقوق اذا دعني اقول امريكا لن تزود
بتقنيه متطوره جدا لسببين والسبب الاول
حتى لا يكون هناك تجاوز للخطوط الحمراء من
وجهه الروسيه والسبب الثاني لا يقل خطوره
عدم سقوط هذه التقنيه بيد روسيا لاحظ
ايران عندما اسقطت احد الطائرات
الامريكيه المسيره واستفادت من همم ما
يسمى الاتجاه العكسي للتكنولوجيا وطورت
طائرات هذا يعتبر احد المحاذير لا يمكن
لامريكا ان تفرض بها شكرا جزيلا لك همم
لوفاء تدوير على حضورك معنا شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من الكويت الدكتور صالح
المطيري ولديفنا من واشنطن الادميرال
وليام فيلم
بهذا المشاهدين الكلام يكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه
موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل باذن الله
لبحث سيناريوهات جديده مرتبطه باحداث
عربيه ودوليه في امان الله
[موسيقى]